we were so excited when the trailer for
the new movie The Grinch drops the new
holiday film looks totally awesome stay
tuned to find out the scoop about the
new animated movie if you love animated
movies as much as we do be sure to
subscribe to the things now let's get to
everything we know about the 2018 Grinch
movie trailers the trailers for the
Grinch looks amazing AF the first
trailer that dropped gave us kind of a
day in the life of the Grinch vibe we
see him wake up to Pharrell's happy even
though he's basically the grouchiest guy
ever
and then we see his trusty dog max
prepare his coffee and help him get
dressed did you go into Whoville to do
mean things like spitting out a pickle
and putting it back in someone's jar
isn't that disgusting we get a little
hint that it's Christmas time with the
giant Christmas decorations that
literally punched the Grinch in the face
poor guy the second trailer gives us a
bit more of the story and a lot more max
the dog the beginning of the trailer
tells us it's never too early to get
annoyed by Christmas we've got a lot of
people find this relatable since
Christmas music and stuff seems to start
earlier every year we get to see a
flashback to the Grinch is sad childhood
and hatches bland is still Christmas and
this trailer has an awesome jazzy
version of you're a mean one mr. Grinch
playing in the background we can't wait
to hear the whole song the title dr.
Seuss his original story was called How
the Grinch Stole Christmas and that's
pretty much exactly what the story is
there's an old-school animated version
of the story too we mean super
old-school
it was a TV movie in 1966 talk about a
throwback we don't get a lot of the
Grinch's backstory or a day-to-day life
in the book or old cartoon and then in
2000 the live-action version was
released it was a huge hit and became a
Christmas classic this version starred
Jim Carrey as the Grinch we get some
flashbacks to his childhood in this
version so we know why he hates
Christmas and he makes an elaborate plan
to
still Christmas just like in the book
but the new movie is just called the
Grinch
we don't know why they shortened the
title but it sure is easier to say maybe
they just figured everyone would call it
that anyway
or maybe the focus isn't as much about
stealing Christmas as previous versions
it may focus a lot more on the Grinch
himself instead of his evil plan but we
do know he will try to sow Christmas
from the trailer I become Santa Claus to
steal Christmas who knows why they
shortened it whatever it's called we're
still totally pumped benedict
cumberbatch we don't know much about the
entire cast of The Grinch but we do know
it stars Benedict Cumberbatch as the
voice of the Grinch how cool is that
this actor has gotten super famous in
recent years so we're pretty sure you'll
recognize him he got famous from
starring as Sherlock Holmes in the BBC
series Sherlock but he went totally
mainstream when he played dr. strange in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe films he
was a huge hit in that role he had his
own Marvel movie and then he was
featured in Avengers infinity Wars in
2018 where else have you seen the
British actor he played Khan in the 2013
movie star trek into darkness he's no
stranger to voicing roles either he was
the voice of the computer-generated
dragon Smaug in The Hobbit movies - he
was great at that so we know he's got
voice acting down but this is the first
time we've seen him in a mainstream kids
movie he's a pretty great actor and he
proved that with dr. strange that he can
play a pretty grumpy dude we know he
will be awesome as the Grinch do you
think he's the right guy to voice The
Grinch the director duo
the new branch movie has not one but two
awesome directors you may not recognize
their names but we know you'll recognize
some of the movies they've worked on
yaro Chaney is no stranger to animated
movies he's worked as a CGI animator on
the 1999 film Iron Giant he was also a
production designer for Despicable Me
and Despicable Me 2 Wow he's worked on
some great movies he's also no stranger
to the style of dr. Seuss he was a
production designer and character
designer for the 2012 animated feature
The Lorax
isn't that cool we know
we'll be right at home with the Grinch
this isn't his first time co-directing
an animated movie either
he was a co-director for The Secret Life
of pets from the same studio that's
doing the new Grinch movie he's teamed
up with Scott Mosier for this movie
Moser is pretty new to the animated
world but he's got a great background in
producing and writing for classic comedy
movies like clerks and mall rats he's
known for his humor so this new movie
should be hilarious they seem like an
unlikely duo but they each bring some
awesome talent to the table this Grinch
film is going to be lits origin story
one thing the original How the Grinch
Stole Christmas doesn't really address
is just by the Grinch hates Christmas so
much that he wants to steal it in the
2000 film starring Jim Carrey we see
that he was adopted by two Whovian
ladies who loved him but he was very
bullied that led him to living life as a
hermit that scared everyone the new
trailer shows us something very
different we get a glimpse of a young
Grinch living in an orphanage and
imagining a tree with lots of presents
that is just so sad we also noticed that
he seems to walk through the town
without everyone running away in fear so
he seems to be less of a hermit the head
of the studio has said that this movie
will be more of an origin story why is
the Grinch the way he is why is his
heart three sizes too small
also the 2000 version of How the Grinch
Stole Christmas was really about how too
many people get caught up in the things
of Christmas instead of the spirit of
the season this new movie focuses on how
the innocence of cindy-lou who could
transformed a very cynical tiny heart of
the Grinch we love that this is going to
be a fresh new take on the classic story
illumination films this new animated
Christmas movie is not a Pixar movie
it's not a DreamWorks movie either
instead it is from the increasingly
popular studio illumination Matt Guf
this studio doesn't have a ton of
feature films out but the ones that have
made have been huge hits all three
Despicable Me movies plus minions are
illumination films those movies are huge
successes this studio also made sting
and The Secret Life of pets which are
both super popular animated movies all
their movies are known for the
larious and well-written they are always
full of bright cgi animation Chris slow
and Ari is the head of the France based
studio he's had a lot to say about the
new Grinch movie you may be wondering
why they are remaking a movie that was
already be made in 2000 and you wouldn't
be alone but Melander wants people to
know that the Grinch is a fresh new take
on a classic story he really delved into
what he thinks dr. Seuss's original
meaning was he thinks it's much more
about the character transformation than
the commercialization of Christmas
excited stay tuned to find out about the
release of the film the animals who
doesn't love a great cartoon dog
sometimes they are the best part of an
animated movie we are super excited to
see the Grinch's trusty dog max the
trailers show us how max makes the
Grinch's coffee with a frowning face
every morning hey where can we get a
coffee making dogs that would be totally
whipped we know that max is loyal to his
grumpy owner and he can even play chess
oh no it looks like he prefers fetch as
the Grinch easily cheats by throwing a
dog toy
max is adorable and he's smart a AB the
trailer also shows us another animal
that will be starring in the movie The
Grinch tries to catch a reindeer
probably for his plan to steal Christmas
from the who's he ends up stealing a
very fat reindeer who is super cute he's
really hairy with a party to on top of
his head The Grinch calls him Fred as he
comes down the stairs
what are you doing the reindeer is
totally eating a ton of whipped cream
and it starts to come out of his nose
gross we are excited to see all the new
characters in the Grinch
especially Fred and the updated take on
max a modern take it's not just the
story that is getting an update if you
take a look at the two trailers you can
see that they've really modernized the
setting of the story The Grinch flies
max on some sort of drone with some
high-tech software he's got a very
elaborate coffee making machine that
even a dog can use even his bath time
routine is high-tech Louisville also
looks quite a bit more modern although
it still totally has the crazy Seuss
vibe even the grocery store looks like a
store you might see with just some Seuss
touches the who the ends themselves
managed to look like they belong in the
2018 movie while also having the same
who noses that dr. Seuss designed the
Grinch is alarm clock plays a modern
song and the new version of your mean
one mr. Grinch has an updated vibe while
maintaining a jazzy throwback sound
it's pretty amazing that illumination
studios were able to take such an old
story and update it so well and they did
a great job maintaining the old
Seussville - are you excited to see what
other modern updates the movie has so
are we
Seuss movies The Grinch is just the
latest dr. Seuss movie to get a
cinematic makeover of course the story
of everyone's favorite grumpy Green guy
is the third remake of the classic book
after the success of the live-action
Grinch a real-life Cat in the Hat movie
came out in 2003 it wasn't nearly as
successful as How the Grinch Stole
Christmas was though in 2008 20th
Century Fox started the animated Seuss
trends with Porton gears ahooo it
starred Jim Carrey as the voice of
Horton that's right he's the same guy
who played the Grinch in 2000 in 2012
illumination Studios made their first
Seuss movie The Lorax was a pretty great
animated movie starring Danny DeVito as
the Lorax
who speaks for the trees it had some
great messages about taking care of the
environment but it was also just really
funny it did pretty well at the box
office isn't it awesome that dr. Seuss
wrote so many amazing stories that are
seriously timeless dr. Seuss movies can
be pretty hit or miss so keep your
fingers crossed for the Grinch it sure
looks like it will be an awesome holiday
movie though
we bet it goes down in Hollywood history
as a Christmas movie classic really
States and now the moment you've been
waiting for
when does this awesome new movie come
out drum roll please the release date in
the United States and many other
countries is November 9th 2018 it's
pretty much the perfect time for this
movie to come out don't you think it's
not too early that seen a Christmas
movie will be weird and it's not too
late for the holiday season it should
have a nice long Christmas run at the
movies some other countries like
Australia and New Zealand may have to
wait a couple more weeks but don't worry
it will still be out in plenty of time
before Christmas you can bat we will be
there opening weekend will you this
timeless tell will be a huge hit right
before the holidays and we'll have
plenty of time to watch it a million
times before Christmas we can't wait for
more details about the movie to drop who
do you think will place two new boo boo
why do you think the Grinch hates
Christmas so much will this heart grow
three
one day don't be shy come let us know
what you think in the comments we always
love to hear your thoughts and that's
everything we know about the 2018 movie
The Grinch stay up-to-date on all the
best movies and TV shows by subscribing
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up